[Applause]
is it true that your kids weren't
allowed to watch
tv but then maybe during the pandemic
that changed yeah yeah things obviously
changed for everyone during the pandemic
and uh
you know we i just never had a tv i was
always outside
mountain climbing skateboarding my mom
just got me out so
um and my wife didn't really you know
she wasn't uh
having the tv around she was just
working so i think when we met
we never had one and when we raised the
kids we'd watch the movies here and
there
but you know they're big into reading
and getting out outdoors and so
now uh i embraced it and we were
watching uh
or watching netflix and you know i saw
stranger things and the kids wanted to
watch
it and man it was awesome
so then we went down the rabbit hole of
like okay
but it was just beautiful family time
cuddled up just two babies under my arm
and i got excited just to watch him
we missed mama and so we started
watching cosby's and
man just watching you know
that whole you know just seeing her when
she was little
and and the babies getting to see her
and it was it was phenomenal what did
your kids think when they saw
their mom on cosby they just i mean lola
100 just fell in love like she just
she watches it still so i she just loves
it
wolfie's definitely more into the action
stuff and so we've been slowly
introducing some of mine but
my stuff's pretty not kid appropriate so
um they don't really i don't know
they've went everywhere with us you know
even when i did game of thrones and i'm
covered in blood you know lola's just
sitting there knitting and
in the corner i'm like hey baby and i'm
just like ripping people's throats out
and
she just you know you're just being
silly papa so
i love it cal drogo come on it's the
greatest thing
in the world you literally changed the
world that's all we all talked about
for months years was you and khaleesi
that's it
that was like as if there was nothing
else to talk about but carol and
khaleesi that's it
it's a fun show thank you now jason
um we have had such a pleasure speaking
with you
today your insights about life family
the world humanity
and everything that we're capable of
have been so inspiring
and i was wondering if we could play a
little game with you sure
um mamoa in a minute
[Applause]
[Music]
okay uh i'm gonna fire off some
questions your way
and you'll have uh a quick minute to
answer them are you ready
oh gosh yes okay number one what's your
worst habit
it's no worse habit oh
i'm always on time oh god
i'm always oh god
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right um who's your first celebrity
crush
this boy i knew it i knew it okay uh
biggest aphrodisiac
uh oysters
um guilty pleasure guilty pleasure
um i ride motorcycles that involve gas
and oil which i'm trying to steer away
to
e guilty pleasure i love riding
motorcycles
absolutely that goes as a guilty
pleasure uh boxers or briefs
uh boxer briefs oh sensible
last text you sent last
text i sent uh to
i mean to my to my daughter and my son
it's under
the babies i love you i'm gonna be on
drew barry more right now
[Applause]
okay um excuse me
biggest regret oh
oh i don't do that good
i made this i made the choice i don't i
don't regret i just
god no good i'm
again i'm like okay gosh okay oh um what
do you smell like
campfire
jeez probably gasoline
oil and uh hawaiian flowers there you go
hence the new aphrodisiac ladies and
gentlemen
age of your first kiss he's on my first
kiss
jesus drew um probably
12 12. gosh my kids are 12. no push it
later
14. i know by the way no 14 little wolf
14
15. take your time oh god try going to
studio 54
at seven and telling your kids to go to
school the last time you cried
last time i cried oh last week
i cry a lot
enough already with you okay have you
eaten anything off the floor
oh yeah look at me
i have two um jason
i don't know where to begin but let this
never end our love fest with you
really yeah you're amazing thank you
drew thank you
for setting our show up on the right
path in
every sense of the word the real aquaman
i we all love you so much jason mananalu
water
is available online and select west
coast retailers of course
and um thank you you're the exact
superhero we need in movies and
in real life it doesn't work if you
don't recycle it
so this just is important it's going in
the recycle
and thank you so much
you